so Emily and I have been talking about
how natural selection Darwin's theory of
evolution has differed from some of the
ways that people have interpreted
evolution over time and specifically was
interested in this group known as the
social Darwinists who were mostly a
group of sociologists and other sort of
public policymakers we're trying to
apply Darwin's theories to how the world
should be ordered and how races should
relate to each other classes should
relate to each other basically how this
idea of evolution could be used to
explain the world around them in a
social way so Emily you were explaining
to me how natural selection actually
works so just as like a quick recap on
the way that natural selection works at
biological populations is that there's
some variation in the population that's
heritable meaning that it's it's in the
organism's genes and it can be passed on
to offspring and if that variation
affects how well the organism can
survive and reproduce
so if it affects how many offspring is
able to leave behind in the next
generation then it's possible for
certain traits that are well suited to
the organisms immediate environment to
become more and more common in the
population over generations so that's
that's kind of the idea of natural
selection in a nutshell right and we
also talked about the fact that there's
no such thing as one race or one
organism being more evolved than another
organism because we've all been evolving
this whole time so what I'd like to do
now is just to talk about some of the
ways that the sociologists of this time
kind of Miss applied Darwin's theories
and just get your opinions on how what
they were saying actually relates with
how biology really works so Herbert
Spencer was a sociologist from England -
he's actually the person who coined the
term survival of the fittest which i
think is interesting so it wasn't Darwin
who coined this term but rather Spencer
and I think what was animating people
like Spencer and other social Darwinists
in this time was just to say why are
some people in a better social position
than others so why are some people poor
versus rich
why do African Americans or people from
colonized nations have a worse situation
in the world than people in civilized
nations or civilized kind of in air
quotes from that time period and what
Spencer said was oh this must be
Darwinism right it must be that people
who are wealthy are better adapted to
their environment they're more evolved
than people who are poor so I think this
this idea of difference between the
classes was one of the first animations
behind the idea of social Darwinism so
is there any way that that actually
relates to how biology explains
Darwinism I mean I think that that's
really a case of an idea from biology
being not very accurately applied to
society on yeah I think that there was
probably a strong motivation for someone
in Spencer's position to want to explain
things in that way because that would
justify inaction on his part and sort of
say that this is acceptable because it's
quote/unquote natural odd and you know I
think that it's really not a very
scientific or even an investigated
perspective I think that it was sort of
an effort to fit something sort of a
round peg in a square hole so to speak
yeah it's interesting as I've been
learning more about this what I've
noticed that people in general seem to
take up one of these explanations for
like how the universe works and then try
to apply it to everything even if it
might not necessarily apply so yeah I
think I think your word inaction here is
is really accurate because one of the
things that Spencer is just wondering
about is like should the government do
something for people who are poor for
people who are in a bad
position and he basically says no
because his idea is that if the
government helps them then you're
interfering with this survival of the
fittest and that those sorts of people
should naturally be bred out of the
populace to make our the race more
evolved so is there any truth into this
idea that you could make the human race
more evolved by breeding out certain
parts of it my tendency would be to say
that any program designed to reduce
variation in a biological population is
probably not going to be beneficial for
that population okay
so that's kind of a broad statement but
on you know if if you look at factors
that make endangered species endangered
one of the big ones is that they have
very low genetic variation their gene
pool and that means that harmful gene
versions are more likely to come
together in the same individual so it's
more likely for there to be genetic
defects genetic disorders on in general
a high level of variation is an
indicator of a healthy population and a
low level of variation or any population
where you have intensive inbreeding of
similar individuals that's going to be a
populations probably less healthy
interesting because there's this very
popular movement in the United States
and then moving on to places like
Germany where we see this very strongly
in the Holocaust of eugenics right that
the idea that you can make your your
race more in your country more evolved
more fit this survival of the fittest by
breeding out certain things that are
termed undesirable I mean in terms of
long term population survival from a
biological standpoint I don't see how
that could be beneficial and you never
know what's down the road you never know
if there's a new infectious disease
that's going to show up and who's going
to be resistant to it somebody who has
genetic variation that doesn't matter
right now but you don't know who that's
going to be so it's that sort of general
principle applies that the reason
variation is great is it prepares a
population to deal with an uncertain
future this is
so interesting to me because I think you
see this a lot in history because people
in some ways here they're very much
confusing culture for biology right
because in many cases they're saying
that traits that they see as culturally
undesirable you know looking through the
eyes of white supremacy of sort of this
racial and cultural supremacy of people
from England from the United States from
Western Europe you know they're they're
looking around them and they see people
who are different from them and they
ascribe that to a kind of biological
inferiority when in fact it's just a
cultural difference I think that that's
a very good way to state it I think that
there's just a big conflation here of
cultural and biological and applying
ideas that might be great for one and in
a place where they're not actually as
well-suited and I think it one thing
that also interests me about this is the
the way that things like eugenics are
used as justifications and using
Darwinism as a justification for not
helping certain people for saying oh you
know you're less evolved you belong at
the bottom of the social scale and if I
help you then I'm not helping us evolve
as a race with also kind of a flipside
of saying oh we must help certain
cultures become more civilized and you
see that a lot in the era of colonialism
which is also big in the Gilded Age is
kind of becoming a world event in the
Gilded Age as England begins to take
colonies in India and Africa and other
nations do the same one of the
justifications that they're giving is
these people are less civilized than us
they're less evolved than us and so we
have to help them it's the white man's
burden phrase by Rudyard Kipling to help
these other races evolve yeah I mean
that's the very definite conflation of
biological and social I mean teaching
people to behave in a different way does
not affect their biology that was
actually one of Spencer's misconceptions
he was an adherent of Lamarckian
evolution which would suggest that if
you gain a trait during your lifetime
you will biologically and genetically
pass it on to
offspring and you may pass it on to your
offspring by teaching them something but
genetic traits that are acquired during
your life you don't pass those on you
actually don't generally inherit the
acquired genetic traits exactly so I
think that that definitely reflects the
confusion in terms of what biological
evolution is and how it works
mechanistically yeah so I think I think
if there's anything for us to take away
from this it's that one that there's no
such thing as one person being more
evolved than another person we're one
race being more evolved than another
race I think there's actually not much
of a biological basis for the concept of
race to start with since human beings
are biologically but like 99.9% the same
yeah I mean from everything that I've
seen race is really something that
people have come up with in an effort to
categorize the world around them but
it's not actually reflected very
meaningfully in people's genetics you
know there are certain very superficial
physical traits that are inherited that
we defined as quote unquote race but if
you actually look at the genomes of the
people who belong to a particular racial
group that is socially defined there's a
huge amount of variation there and
there's much more variation within what
we would consider a race then there are
differences that separate races it's
basically is a pretty arbitrary way to
categorize people